bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
en dire sur figaro live dans quelques
minutes se déroulera la cérémonie du nom
les deux jumelles pandas nés au zoo de
beauval en août dernier vont se voir
attribuer des noms officielle en
présence du champion du monde qui lie à
demba paix et de la championne olympique
chinoise de plongeon zhangjiajie excusez
moi pour la prononciation ses deux stars
internationales deviennent par la même
occasion le parrain et la marraine des
deux bébés pandas à partir de ce jour
donc leur surnom temporaire donné depuis
leur naissance à savoir fleurs de coton
et petites neiges disparaîtront au
profit de leurs noms officiels chinois
comme le veut la tradition une véritable
fête donc va être célébré en grande
pompe à beauval en présence de nombreux
médias et pour la grande joie des
spectateurs et futurs visiteurs du zoo
mais pas que parce que derrière cette
mise en scène d'apparence bon enfant se
cache en réalité une véritable stratégie
diplomatique
je vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet ce
que nous disait ce matin sébastien
falletti correspondant du figaro en asie
il répondait à mes questions pour figaro
live bonjour sébastien falletti
bonjour vous êtes correspondant en asie
pour pour le figaro alors aujourd'hui
les deux jumelles pandas nés au zoo de
beauval en france en août dernier vont
faire l'objet d'une cérémonie en grande
pompe en présence du champion du monde
qu'il ya même happé par un français de
l'un de ces deux pandas et puis avec lui
la chinoise zhang yang jaqee l'autre
marraine est championne olympique de
plongeon et tous les deux vont révéler
cet après-midi les non officiels de ces
deux ursidés c'est un livre c'est un
événement à la fois festif et
attendrissant que beaucoup attendent
mais cette cérémonie du nom comme on se
doit de la plaie est elle pas plus
politique qu'il n'y paraît sébastien
oui alors effectivement les pandas ont
une fonction dans le dispositif
diplomatique chinois ils ont tué un
lourd fardeau à porter contraint
beaucoup d'autres animaux puisque ils
appartiennent officiellement à la
république populaire de chine donc tous
les quelques camps panda qui sont
autour de la planète sont pour
l'essentiel la propriété de la chine qui
les prêtent et les loue fort cher
d'ailleurs aux différents os et aux
différents pays donc lorsque la chine
veut faire un geste envers un autre pays
pour affirmer ses relations proches avec
ce pays at elle a souvent tradition
d'offrir un panda ou un bébé panda mais
ce panda et les animaux qu'ils les
éventuels descendants de ce pont d'ascq
ont repris et est de la chine donc c'est
un petit peu comme s'il y avait une
sorte d'extra territorialité
appliquée au genre animal est donc dans
ces cas là c'est une façon de dire voilà
on c'est un outil pour établir une bonne
relation avec un pays
mais on la chine garde le contrôle de
cette de ce don même par delà la
frontière
à travers ce que vous dites on peut
rebondir sur sur cette définition qui a
été donnée à cette forme de diplomatie
on appelle ça la la diplomatie du panda
on est proche de ce qu'on peut appeler
aujourd'hui du soft power est-ce qu'on
peut aller jusqu'à parler de propagande
sébastien falletti
alors tout cas ça vise à projeter une
image positive de la chine à l'étranger
c'est un des axes centraux du président
chez jean ping depuis qu'il est arrivé
au pouvoir il y a en 2013 il a beaucoup
insisté sur cet aspect et encore
récemment il insisté sur le fait qu'il
faut que la chine est une image aimable
selon cette merde et c'est un défi
d'autant plus pressant que la chine
l'image de la chine s'est nettement
dégradée notamment dans les pays en
développement en développer pardon
depuis ces dernières années en
particulier depuis la pandémie tous les
sondages montrent que l'image de la
chine se dégradent parce que en
parallèle la diplomatie chinoise a une
position aussi plus décomplexée plus
l'offensive voire agressive et puis on
sait qu'il ya eu des reprises en mains à
hong kong des menaces sur taïwan
une affirmation face à l'unfp en mer de
chine donc la chine s'impose se montrent
de plus en plus ferme sur la scène
internationale elle a aussi des
diplomates beaucoup plus agressif
notamment l'ambassadeur de chine à paris
louchats yeux fait partie de ceux qu'on
appelle les loups guerrier donc pour là
on ne parle pas de pandas on parle de
lucgarier c'est-à-dire de diplomates qui
osent parler très fort tapé du poing sur
la table et kita a attaqué publiquement
des personnes des journalistes notamment
des militants ou des mêmes des
représentants
d'autres pays si on considère qu'ils ont
critiqué la chine donc on a une
diplomatie de beaucoup plus décomplexée
et en parallèle il y à un volonté de
pékin de d'améliorer image donc on peut
voir une forme de contradiction
évidemment dans cette panoplie le panda
c'est quelque chose qui touche les
foules qui touche petits et grands ça ne
paraît pas politique et j'ajouterais
qu'il ya un autre élément dans
l'événement que vous suivez aujourd'hui
c'est aussi l'élément sportif vous avez
vu qu'il y avait donc qu'il y en ai bavé
et une championne chinoise ce n'est pas
anodin car il faut savoir que la chine
veut faire du sport aussi un vecteur
d'image il y a les jeux olympiques de
pékin qui s'ouvre dans quelques mois
jeux olympiques d'hiver où la chine veut
vraiment faire une vitrine pour montrer
qu'elle est un pays un grand pays qui
s'est organisé ces événements est aussi
un pays qui n'est pas isolé sur la scène
internationale est aujourd'hui un des
problèmes pour la chine c'est que sa
stratégie diplomatique très agressive a
pour pendant un risque d'isolement on le
voit notamment de la part des états unis
mots si on voit certains pays européens
qui commencent à est de plus en plus
raide face à la chine donc les
olympiques ou des événements comme il se
lie qui montrent que la chine a des amis
c'est très important donc il ya cet
aspect là qui cet arrière-plan qui plane
sur 7 ce genre de cérémonie
vous qui êtes en asie en permanence
comment les chinois et comment la plus
tôt la célébration des pandas ultra
médiatisé en occident quand elle se
passe en france aux états unis ou en
allemagne est elle perçue par par les
chinois eux-mêmes dans leur propre pays
est-ce que entre guillemets à cette
propagande chinoise fonctionne également
al'inverse quand elle est destinée à
être médiatisé sur le territoire chinois
alors évidemment le panda toujours
beaucoup de succès
populaire aussi avec les enfants aussi
en chine c'est surtout dans la région le
berceau beaucoup de presse se trouvent
dans la région du sichuan à chengdu vous
avez un un endroit où vous pouvez aller
visiter les pandas y s'était fortement
mise en scène donc c'est un animal très
populaire mais cela dit c'est d'abord
une arme à destination de l'étranger les
chinois ne s'identifient pas forcément
au panda c'est un animal qui l'aurait
qui leur est populaire mais il ya
d'autres animaux qui comptent fortement
dans l'imaginaire chinois sur le dragon
le tigre et le panda est vraiment lié à
l'établissement de liens avec
l'extérieur et bien sûr la presse
officielle chinoise va couvrir des
événements lorsqu'un pandas nés à
l'étranger ou lorsque la chine fait un
don mais c'est pour mettre en valeur
justement les activités de la diplomatie
chinoise et l'objectif c'est encore une
fois de montrer que la chine a des amis
la chine est respecté à travers le monde
que donc la chine est un grand pays et
derrière c'est ça qui compte pour les
chinois aujourd'hui c'est l'idée que la
chine est redevenu à sa place quand on
l'appelait longtemps l' empire du milieu
c'était à l'idée que la chine reprend
pleinement sa place après un hiatus au
19ème 20ème siècle aujourd'hui sous
l'égide du parti sous l'égide du
président shipping les chinois veulent
croire qu'ils sont redevenus une grande
puissance et qu'ils peuvent tutoyer un
notamment les états unis c'est ce qu'on
a vu il ya quelques jours avec un tête à
tête entre le président jean ping et le
président joe biden ça c'est très
important
voilà donc l'idée c'est de montrer aux
chinois que nous sommes un pays respecté
alors évidemment une cérémonie comme
celui là ça ne mange pas de pain ça
permet aussi d'alimenter cette idée
auprès du public chinois que nous sommes
respectés et nous sommes aimés et bien
sûr de passer sous silence ces sondages
qui sont beaucoup moins flatteur
et les difficultés dit matic qui sont
réels qui sont en train de s'accumuler
notamment entre la chine et les halles
unis mais aussi entre la chine et
l'europe et entre la chine et la france
il ya beaucoup de contentieux de
discuter sur beaucoup de sujets et ce
sont des choses qui ne sont pas
améliorées qui sont plutôt aggravées ces
derniers mois et dernières années merci
beaucoup sébastien falletti pour pour
tous ces éclairages rappelle que vous
êtes notre correspondant pour le figaro
en asie à bientôt merci à vous revoir
bonjour sébastien fallait si vous venez
nous rejoindre en direct sur figaro live
dans quelques minutes devraient débuter
la cérémonie du nom un événement au
cours duquel la chinoise zhang jati
championne olympique de plongeon
synchronisé et kylie ann m bape est
champion du monde de foot se trouveront
auprès des pandas pour dévoiler le nom
officiel des jumelles pandas nés en août
dernier bonjour antoine bondage merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur figaro
life pour commenter cet événement et
surtout nous livrer une analyse des
coulisses politiques de cette opération
est en quelque sorte une analyse du
pouvoir de ces fameux panda qui plaisent
à beaucoup vous êtes chargé de recherche
à la fondation pour la recherche
stratégique
spécialistes et des deux corées et de la
chine les internautes qui se passionnent
justement pour la diplomatie chinoise
vous connaissent bien ils sont nombreux
à vous suivre sur twitter en particulier
l'opération est donc sans aucun doute
attendrissante et suscite l'enthousiasmé
je disais sur place et sur les réseaux
sociaux l'image du panda débonnaire
rassurer rassemble c'est un bon
ambassadeur le panda alors c'est un
excellent ambassadeur puisque les petits
et les grands sont tous entre guillemets
amoureux de ces de ces animaux et puis
surtout c'est un animal qui est en
demies uniquement à la chine il ya en
réalité assez peu d'animaux entre
guillemets qui sont aussi connus et qui
sont endémiques à un seul pays et puis
il ya aussi très peu de pays qui offrent
on qui prêtent des animaux qui sont
considérés comme des animaux endémiques
on peut parler de certaines tortues qui
avait été offerte par les seychelles à
la chine et quelques années taiwan dans
ses échanges avec la chine avait prêté
mêmes données
la fin des années 2000 des biches qui
sont endémiques de l'île de taïwan en
échange de panda ou alors on peut encore
parler de la mongolie ou de la russie
qui parfois peuvent offrir des chevaux
notamment d'un russie j'ai le souvenir
des chevaux orlov donc c'est assez rare
tradition plutôt asiatiques on va dire
une tradition peut-être plutôt
asiatiques oui surtout chinoises faut
être très clair sur ce point et qui a
profondément évolué en réalité c'est 70
80 dernières années puisque si
aujourd'hui on prête runnymede des
pandas il y a encore quelques décennies
on les donnait tout simplement mais
justement alors qu'on voit en ce moment
en direct des images fournies par la
effets de l'entrée par laquelle
peut-être arrivons les deux parrains de
cette cérémonie dont kylie ann m bape et
cette championne olympique chinoise dont
je vais réciter le nom en essayant de
bien prononcer zhang dati qui sont
réciproquement parrains et marraines de
ses deux jumelles panda dont on devrait
avoir connaissance des noms en direct
dans quelques minutes antoine monde has
on parle souvent de cette diplomatie du
panda le principe de près de la chine
auprès de pays amis est ce que
d'ailleurs c'est un terme exact de
parler de diplomatie du panda est ce
qu'on dirait pas plutôt soft power
aujourd'hui alors on parle beaucoup de
diplomatie du panda il ya également
quelques ouvrages qui ont été écrits ces
dernières années sur le sujet on peut
parler de diplomatie puisque de fait
depuis les années 40 et avant même la
république populaire de chine l'ancêtre
institutionnel est ce qu'on appelait la
république de chine c'est à dire le
régime qui a aujourd'hui à taiwan
avaient commencé à donner des pandas est
le premier exemple c'est 1941 en plein
milieu de la guerre la seconde guerre
mondiale où les nationalistes et
notamment le dirigeant chiang kai shek
va offrir un premier panda aux états
unis on né en 1941 et puis la république
populaire de chine qui arrive au pouvoir
en chine en 1949 va reprendre entre
guillemets n'ont pas cette tradition
mais cette diplomatie entre guillemets
du panda mais là on signale ont très
clairement le virage politique de cette
nouvelle chine entre guillemets en
offrant à l'époque des pandas à la fin
des années 50 à l'urss et puis dans les
années 60 à la corée du nord et puis
dans les années 70 encore une évolution
il faut se rappeler en
1971 l'art public populaire de chine
reprend le siège de la chine au conseil
de sécurité des nations unies et puis
plus largement dans les organisations
onusiennes et puis c'est le début d'un
rapprochement avec des grands pays
occidentaux et à ce moment là la chine
en 72 va offrir à l'époque un panda aux
états unis de nouveaux puits au japon au
royaume uni à l'allemagne et donc on est
à partir des années 70 dans
l'utilisation entre guillemets du panda
pour montrer une évolution de la
politique étrangère chinoise et du
positionnement de la chine sur la scène
internationale est donc en quelque sorte
on peut bien dire que l'eau prom a est
utilisé à des fins politiques pris à des
fins diplomatique et donc il pourrait
donc y avoir une diplomatie du panda est
ce qu'on peut considérer que c'est un
instrument encore aujourd'hui
incontournable de la diplomatie chinoise
et même je les lui en préparant cette
émission peut considérer que c'est là
tout coeur de la diplomatie chinoise oui
alors c'est un des outils de la
diplomatie chinoise mme il faut bien
comprendre que la diplomatie chinoise
s'est considérablement non seulement
professionnaliser en quelque sorte mais
surtout diversifier
complexifier depuis ces dernières
décennies
aujourd'hui la diplomatie chinoise elle
repose avant tout sur la puissance
économique de la chine le siège de
membre permanent du conseil de sécurité
de la chine au sein de du conseil de
sécurité donc des nations-unies et donc
disons que la chine a de très nombreux
leviers mais dans les leviers pour
séduire à l'étranger en dehors du levier
économique et de la promesse par exemple
d'investissement ou autres des leviers
vraiment pur de soft power pour donner
une bonne image de la chine sont
aujourd'hui relativement limité on voit
que la chine et cei à travers là
l'internationalisation des médias d'état
chinois la création de ces gènes il ya
quelques années la volonté d'être
extrêmement présente sur les plates
formes de streaming comme youtube sur
les réseaux sociaux comme twitter la
chine ne parvient pas forcément à donner
une bonne image en tout cas à enrayer la
chute de popularité entre guillemets ou
l'image de plus en plus négative de la
chine à l'étranger et le panda entre
guillemets encore aujourd'hui fait un
peu figure d'exception louis c'est à
dire que il faut reconnaître que la
chine n'a pas essayé ces dernières
années de trop utiliser le panda à des
fins ouvertement politique elle aurait
pu par exemple il y avait à l'époque des
différends avec les états unis récupérer
les pandas de façon beaucoup plus rapide
elles auraient pu menacer de le faire
avec certains pays elle ne l'a pas
forcément faire je pense qu'à la
conscience que ce serait extrêmement
contre-productif pour le faire mais dans
la séparation entre d'un côté séduire et
d'un côté n'ont pas menacé mais mel user
de la force et de la puissance de la
chine disons que le panda reste
aujourd'hui un atout coeur et une carte
maîtresse pour la chine était peut-être
le seul l'un des rares aujourd'hui il
faut être très clair et encore une fois
en terme d'image internationale de
communication internationale cette
cérémonie du panda ne va pas changer en
dessous la foi est très claire les
relations bilatérales entre la france et
la chine entre l'union européenne et la
chine mais permet d'apporter un petit
peu d'oxygène fo est très claire dans
une relation bilatérale qui depuis
plusieurs années de plus en plus
compliqué les sujets de différends
bilatéraux se multiplient il ya très peu
d'avancé sur le sujet en termes de
relations bilatérales et donc au moins
pendant quelques heures quelques jours
on pense un peu à autre chose et on se
rappelle qu'il ya des liens et anciens
entre la france et la chine qu'il faut
évidemment préserver et qu'il ya des
échanges culturels qui sont beaucoup
moins nombreux aujourd'hui du fait
évidemment de la pandémie mais qui sont
extrêmement utiles entre les deux
sociétés la société française à la
société chinoise on peut pas on peut
penser également au jour de l'an chinois
qui est célébrée en france à paris en
particulier et qui chaque année est mis
en avant médiatisé et qui est beaucoup
apprécié par les français qui le
célèbrent également en famille même si
on n'est pas chinois ou d'origine
chinoise si vous venez nous rejoindre en
direct sur figaro l'avait sur youtube et
bien on attend les débuts de cette
cérémonie du nom en présence de clients
demba paix pour l'attribution des noms
officiels de ses jumelles panda voyez
ces images en direct pour l'instant il
ne se passe rien on aurait dû déjà
débuté à 17h cette cérémonie on les
attend ses parrains prestigieux ses
stars internationales du sport en soi de
bons d'ajustement sébastien falletti
mettait en avant l'idée que le sport
doit occuper et occupe déjà une place
très importante dans
l'idée que se fait la chine de
développer et d'améliorer constamment
son image à l'international
alors bien sûr il ça fait plusieurs
années il faut vraiment faire remonter
ces diplomatie sportive de la chine au
début des années 2000 alors évidemment
dès les années 70 certains se
rappelleront la diplomatie du ping pong
entre la chine et les états unis
justement pendant la période de
rapprochement des années 70 mais disons
que la chine sur le plan multilatéral a
beaucoup misé sur le sport à partir du
début des 2000 du moment où pékin savait
que la ville allait accueillir les jeux
olympiques d'été et on a vu une montée
en puissance un très très rapide très
très forte de la chine en termes par
exemple de médailles aux jeux olympiques
encore plus aux jeux paralympiques dans
lequel la chine investit énormément et
aujourd'hui sur les grands sports
internationaux la chine non seulement
investi beaucoup mais aussi des
ambitions très importante on en parle
régulièrement par exemple dans le
football avec des réussites qui sont
limitées pour l'instant dans ce sport
mais qui dans les autres sports et
notamment la natation par exemple et
encore plus le plongeon notamment plutôt
natation synchronisée plongeon est
refilée aux autres ou la chine
évidemment est une des plus grandes
nations aujourd'hui j'imagine que le
choix de la marraine n'est évidemment
évidemment pas anodin on rappelle donc
que la marraine d'un des deux pandas nés
au zoo de beauval en août dernier qui va
se voir attribuer à attribuer un nom
officiel est donc une championne
olympique la championne olympique
chinoise 2 plongeon synchronisé et elle
s'appelle donc dans datchy et elle
remettra elle annoncera ce nom officiel
en présence de nôtre je vais y arriver
deux autres champions du monde de
football qu'il y en ait mbappé on les
attend tous les deux la cérémonie était
prévue à 17 heures on nous annonce que
en tout cas les autres beauval nous
annonce que dans quelques minutes elle
va se produire on est assez impatient de
découvrir cet événement là antoine bon 2
sur cette tradition de près de la chine
de pandas dans les eaux france est en
tout cas beauval à l'international
également vous parliez des états unis
dans les années 70 est ce que j'imagine
que certains internautes se pose la
question est ce que cette cette
diplomatie qu'on qualifie diplomatie du
panda fonctionne alors je ne sais pas si
aujourd'hui elle fonctionne ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que la
diplomatie du panda elle est utile pour
accentuer renforcer une tendance est à
dire que lorsque vous avez une évolution
politique en matière diplomatique et une
nouvelle tendance par exemple le
rapprochement entre la chine et les
états unis dans les années 70 alors le
panda est utile puisqu'il permet
d'amplifier cette tendance est en tout
cas de l'illustré quand vous avez des
tensions bilatérales
le fait de traiter un panda ne va pas
forcément renversé entre guillemets
cette tendance s'est renversée l'état
des relations bilatérales et c'est là
toute la limite mais on peut dire la
même chose sur la question du sport par
exemple ya quelques années vous rappelez
des jeux olympiques d'hiver en corée du
sud où les gens expliqué que c'était
grâce aux jeux olympiques il y avait un
rapprochement intercoréen non c'est
parce qu'il y avait un rapprochement
intercoréen que les jeux olympiques ont
pu avoir une utilité est donc là c'est
la même chose les pandas sont utiles
lorsqu'il y a une tendance politique qui
est favorable lorsque léo lagrange sont
déjà bonnes on va dire lorsqu'elles sont
bonnes en tout cas quand la chine veut
envoyer un message à un pays en disant
qu'elle entend améliorer profondément
les relations par exemple si on prend un
exemple récent non pas la france
puisqu'en 2012 y avait évidemment de
bonnes relations entre paris et pékin
c'est le cas avec taiwan pékin a offert
à la fin des années 2000 deux pandas
elle ne les a pas la donne et elle ne
nous a pas prêté les a offerts en
échange de quatre animaux qui venait de
taiwan dont de biche donc que je
mentionnais précédemment et là la
volonté de pékin était clair c'était de
mettre en scène
d'envoyer un message fort à taïwan à une
époque où les deux rives souhaitait
améliorer les relations alors tu ailles
open taïwan avait refusé ces pandas
initialement au milieu des années 2000
et puis changement de présidence le
président magnaud arrive au pouvoir son
objectif est de mettre en scène un
rapprochement avec le continent avec la
chine et donc à ce moment-là taiwan
acceptent des pandas et donc évidemment
sacré ça renforce une dynamique positive
qui était celle d'un rapprochement entre
les deux rives et on peut dire que c'est
le dernier exemple dans ces 15 dernières
années d'une diplomatie du panda qui a
été utile pour mettre en scène une
évolution politique un virage politique
c'est particulièrement intéressant ce
que vous nous racontez en fin de mandat
ce qui évidemment quand on voit des
images de deux naissances de pandas
quand on voit des pandas qui s'amuse de
façon un peu pataud dans certains jeux
internationaux et dont on a les images
sur les réseaux sociaux et bien on ne
soupçonne pas qu effectivement quand il
s'agit d'une cérémonie comme celle qu'on
attend aujourd'hui en france eh ben il y
as derrière une stratégie en
l'occurrence la stratégie d'un pays
comme la chine qui vise à effectivement
ou conforter ou améliorer ses relations
avec avec le pays à qui elle prête
évidemment ces ursidés les images que
vous voyez en ce moment sont des images
d'archivés qui remonte à il ya quelques
semaines au zoo de beauval c'est la
maman panda
qui s'occupe de
ses deux jumelles panda je rappelle
qu'elles sont nés ses deux jumelles en
août dernier qu'elles ont un peu plus de
trois mois aujourd'hui et qu'on attend
cette cérémonie en présence de killian
mba paix pour l'attribution des noms
officiels à consonance chinoise je crois
antoine banda's puisque pour l'instant
elles ont des noms provisoires ces deux
petites femelles pandas fleurs de coton
et petite neige elles ont beaucoup
changé depuis leur naissance vous vous
souvenez certainement de ces images à
leur naissance ne soupçonne pas qu'elles
vont devenir des pandas ça ressemble
plutôt à des embryons animaux et puis
finalement aujourd'hui ce sont des
pandas géants en miniature qu'on peut
voir en l'occurrence on les voyait il ya
quelques instants sur sur ces images
vous le voyez les images pour l'instant
qu'on a seulement c'est celle de la fp1
on attend celle des diot de beauval et
l'arrivée dont des deux parrains la
championne de natation de plongeon
pardon olympique chinoise et le champion
de foot français kilian est mbappé qui
doivent tous les deux en tant que parent
attribué ce nom officiel antoine monde
at on parlé d' efficacité du de cette
stratégie effectivement une stratégie
une efficacité relative est ce que dans
le contexte d'aujourd'hui de cette
pandémie dont on est encore
sous le soul sous l'emprise on va dire
est ce que les pandas à un événement
comme aujourd'hui arrive à faire un peu
contrepoids face aux effets dévastateurs
effectivement de cette pandémie dont on
sait qu'elle est qu'elle est partie un
peu de rouge burhan en chine alors ce
qui est clair c'est que cette cérémonie
km apporter un peu d'oxygène encore une
fois dans une relation bilatérale qui
est extrêmement tendues ces derniers
mois et ces quelques dernières années
et ça permet également de rappeler
l'importance un des relations entre le
peuple français entre guillemets le
peuple chinois c'est ce qu'on appelle
souvent les échanges de personne à
personne c'est à dire qu'en delà des
échanges entre les gouvernements entre
le gouvernement français et le
gouvernement chinois il faut évidemment
privilégier les échanges entre les
peuples les personnes en règle générale
que ce soit à traire le tourisme or
évidemment aujourd'hui il ne peut plus y
avoir de tourisme à destination de la
chine ou en tout cas c'est extrêmement
compliqué de s'y rendre y compris pour
les femmes et les d'affaires est donc
entre guillemets c'est panda permettent
de symboliser un des aspects de la
relation bilatérale entre la france et
la chine faut pas oublier aussi que
c'est un moyen parfois d'accéder au plus
haut niveau de l'état on se rappelle que
la première dame mme brigitte macron
était venu seulement lors de la
naissance des deux jumelles au mois
d'août et il faut bien comprendre que
lorsque vous êtes un diplomate est aussi
un bon moyen de rencontrer les
dirigeants d'un pays et à ce moment là
par exemple l'ambassadeur de chine au
chalet était garanti l'avoir entre
guillemets un entretien avec la première
dame donc ça peut être aussi utile pour
fluidifier les relations pour trouver un
espace de discussions de dialogue en
dehors évidemment de l'agenda officiel
après je pense que ce qu'il est aussi
très important de rappeler c'est les
efforts qui ont été consentis en chine
mais aussi en lien avec le reste du
monde pour la préservation de ces
animaux absolument et s'asseoit sur la
bande à ras-bord décès aux siens à la
bonne évolution
dont on va préciser si je retrouve mes
notes que après des décennies de déclin
leur population a désormais augmenté de
17 % en dix ans grâce justement à la
mise en place de programmes de
conservation et de réserve naturelle le
prêt à des pays étrangers comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui depuis des dizaines
d'années est ce que c'est la seule façon
de préserver cet animal alors non
puisque évidemment aujourd'hui on est
quasiment à 1700 1800 pandas en liberté
en chine en plus évidemment des centres
de reproduction dont sébastien falletti
par là qui seront principalement dans la
province du sichuan donc le panda n'est
plus considérée aujourd'hui comme une
espèce menacée oui c'est une espèce
évidemment qui fait l'objet d'une
surveillance spécifique mais elle n'est
plus comme c'était le cas il ya quelques
décennies comme menacées d'extinction ou
autre et il faut bien reconnaître que à
partir des années 80 il ya eu un
mouvement pour la conservation des
pandas extrêmement important qui a
débuté en chine dès
1980 où 83 avec une première loi sur la
protection des pandas et puis la
multiplication de partenariats
internationaux notamment avec les états
unis notamment avec le zoo de san diego
focal voir les faciliter la reproduction
des pandas alors voilà ça bouge sur ces
images
fusée pour l'instant par l' effet on
attend celle du zoo de beauval
où on voit évidemment les médias qui se
sont massés aujourd'hui en nombre pour
assister à cet événement donc de la
cérémonie du nom je vous rappelle que
les deux jumelles panda dont on a
beaucoup parlé début août après leur
naissance ont bien grandi elles font
maintenant on me demande sur internet
d'ailleurs c'est sylvie qui me demande
combien pèse ses jumelles je ne sais pas
mais en tout cas elle ressemble à des
mini de pandas géants on voit et elles
ont bien grandi depuis leur naissance
on voit qu'ils aiment bape et sur les
images c'est l'un des deux parrains de
ses jumelles panda on devrait voir
également la championne chinoise de
plongeon synchronisé qui doit être à ses
côtés puisque ce sont tous les deux des
stars internationales du sport qui ont
été choisis pour être parrain et
marraine respectives de ces deux animaux
2 ursidés voilà ils posent pour la photo
ils n'ont pas enlevé leur masse que
c'est dommage mais on est obligé de les
garder évidemment dans de pareilles
circonstances qu'ovide oblige
voilà je crois qu'on est sur le site
même où vivent les pandas au zoo de
beauval
il devrait se rendre justement à
proximité des deux ursidés dans quelques
minutes
alors qu'on entend offre évidemment les
les voix des journalistes qui sont
présents sur place et qui fournit ces
images c'est du direct les aléas du
direct et pour nous en plateau et pour
eux sur place
j'en parlais de salars et les officiels
français on voit je crois jean-baptiste
lemoyne secrétaire d'état rattaché au
ministère des affaires étrangères et de
l'europe au tourisme voilà ça va mais
aussi montre l'importance de cette
cérémonie
est-ce qu antoine bande annonce est à
quand remonte le premier don de panda
fait à la france vous parlez du premier
don fait aux états unis
est-ce qu'en france on sait à quelle
date il a été il a été donné alors je ne
sais pas
les pandas qui sort actuellement au zoo
de beauval ont donc été données en 2012
généralement les pandas qui naissent à
l'étranger retournent en chine après
quelques années encore une fois c'est un
prêt et on va les vendre exactement mais
je n'ai je n'ai pas la date du premier
pandas arrivés en france il y en a eu
avant les autres beauval d'ailleurs je
n'en suis pas sûr alors je vais vous
aider puisque j'ai l'info a priori c'est
en 1973 il s'appelait yen yen et c'était
le premier panda à s'installer
durablement dans un zoo français
donc on a plus d'image quel dommage donc
cohérent avec le début des années 70
voilà pour les passionnés japon
royaume-uni que vous disiez on va le
précise et vous vous vous l'évoquez
évidemment les intérêts diplomatiques
certes mais également économique et à ce
propos le zoo de beauval des bourses par
exemple 750000 euros chaque année pour
se faire prêter ses animaux il ya donc
effectivement un lien entre accord
économique est arrivée d'un panda on
imagine quel type d'accords économiques
d'ailleurs a été scellée avec la france
et la chine qui a permis le prêt d'un
panda alors il faut être très clair ce
n'est pas forcément une opération
financière côté chinois cet argent vise
avant tout à couvrir les besoins entre
guillemets du panda et compris les
besoins en termes de soins puisque
généralement des équipes chinoises
viennent résider dans le zoo qui
accueille des pandas pour s'occuper de
ces pandas en lien avec évidemment les
équipes vétérinaires sur place après il
faut bien comprendre que pour le zoo de
beauval c'est évidemment une excellente
opportunité qui a permis de faire
grandir la population la fréquentation
du zoo qui a permis de faire du zoo de
beauval aujourd'hui en france une
référence une référence ou est très
claire et les pandas ont vraiment eu un
rôle extrêmement important non pas si on
va citer quelques chiffres alors qu'on
allait les images du zoo de beauval de
ce cortège d'officiels qui se rendent
sur le site où se trouvent les pandas
afin de donner officiellement les deux
noms assez jeune panda né en août
dernier
à propos donc d'opérations financières
elle est très intéressante pour le zoo
beauval depuis 2012 et l'arrivée de ces
pandas en 2020 le zoo a cueilli un
million de visiteurs contre 600 milles
en 2011 on peut citer le pic à 1
millions 6,2 visiteurs en 2019 avant la
pandémie le chiffre d'affaires du zoo de
beauval a également bénéficié largement
de la présence de ces ursidés puisque
son chiffre d'affaires a plus que triplé
sur la période de 2011 à 2016 passant de
20 millions d'euros à 70 millions
d'euros
vous le site y ait un vous en parliez
antoine bondage alors qu'on voit qu'il
ya même bape et masque est entré dans
une pièce où ils seront je crois
derrière une vitre devant les pandas on
va voir ça dans quelques secondes vous
parliez des vétérinaires dédié chinois
qui se déplacent spécifiquement pour
s'occuper de ses animaux en plus des
équipes sur place au zoo de beauval donc
de quelle mesure la chine a la mainmise
sur la gestion des pandas beauval il
faut être clair les protocoles
vétérinaires sont mis en place par la
chine puisque ce sont les vétérinaires
chinois qui ont l'expérience évidemment
à travers les différents sites de
reproduction ou tout simplement de
d'observation des pandas en chine
j'avais moi même il ya une dizaine
d'années la chance de visiter le centre
de reproduction des pandas qui est dans
la banlieue de chengdu donc dans la
province du sichuan et ce sont des
moyens qui sont extrêmement importants
pour favoriser la reproduction d'un
animal dont la reproduction est
compliquée et donc c'est pour ça que la
naissance les naissances à l'étranger
sont relativement rares il faut s'en
féliciter et c'était une excellente
nouvelle évidemment cet été d'apprendre
la naissance de deux jumelles en france
on voit qu'il ya des maps est sûre sur
ces images qui se positionne pour les
photographes
je ne sais pas où se trouve là la
championne olympique chinoise
si elle est véritablement à ses côtés
puisque alors elle était auparavant avec
le manteau bleu c'est à dire la doudoune
bleue je ne sais pas si c est là oui
voilà l'autre absolument elle est en
doudoune longue bleu ciel sur la gauche
de l'image oui vont dévoiler
effectivement les noms qui sont cachés
pour l'instant sous des
tentures remarque que l'ambassadeur
de chine en france le reste est à gauche
allié qui étaient là lors de la
naissance des jumelles en présence de la
première dame mme brigitte macron n'est
pas présent donc en tout cas n'apparaît
pas sur les images de cette cérémonie
d'une eau comme on peut l'appeler penser
qu'il n'est pas présent je ne sais pas
en tout cas ce qui est intéressant c'est
de montrer que l'ambassade entre
guillemets n'est pas au premier rang aux
premières loges donc c'est aussi
important voilà c'est avant tout une
cérémonie pour baptiser les pandas c'est
pas une cérémonie politique et c'est une
bonne chose très bonne chose que ce soit
ainsi
deux stars du sport de stars
internationales du sport une star
chinoise une star internationale
française qu'il y avait ma paie à votre
droite sur l'écran et la championne
olympique chinoise zhang yan shi
championnat de plongeon synchronisé à
les voilà les pandas qui arrive
évidemment on ne peut pas s'empêcher de
sourire façades et des animaux qui ont
cette allure puisque c'est extrêmement
attendrissant
on laisse vivre un peu ces images
on n'a pas de sens en retour si on peut
monter le son des images on peut voir
venir
[Musique]
qui a même papé
et jeux d'écart cette cérémonie du nom
ouverte
nous avons la joie de vous présenter
celle qui s'appelle encore petite neige
et fleurs de coton
et je vais demander à zhangjiajie et
madame ue de bien vouloir dévoiler le
nom de fleur de coton qui va désormais
en changer je rappelle que vous avez été
plus de 122 milles à voter pour ces noms
attention
je crois que je crois que c'est à vous
de dire le nom
manèges papa maman 2 min
lee et nate tyler farrar joe diop ali
talât tout va aller en guadeloupe
chin shan a tranché y at il un jour à un
taulier par bastian 30 jardin mais radio
1 pour expliquer la signification du nom
officiel la première syllabe baroin
provient du nom de son amant or on est
les deux dernières syllabes provient de
la prononciation chinoise de la capitale
française paris ri cela symbolise
l'amitié qui relie le peuple français au
peuple chinois cela exprime aussi notre
soin pour le plein épanouissement de ses
deux bébés
et
[Applaudissements]
je dois dire que vous avez été plus de
43% à voter pour rendre les les
j'invite il ya même happé et monsieur le
ministre a dévoilé le nom de petites
neiges
je vais peut-être invités tshatshi a
prononcé à roanne du doubs comme ça on
va tout cela prendre want to do
bonjour à tous c'est un grand plaisir
d'être ici voilà c'est un grand moment
pour premier tous un grand moment pour
moi aussi c'est vraiment un énorme
plaisir et une fierté immense de
jeu prend déjà beaucoup de plaisir à
cette cérémonie alors qu'elle vient à
peine de commencer juste de les voir
c'est pour moi j'ai l'honneur d'être
accompagnée d'une grande championne
voilà de vous voir tous ici on va passer
un agréable moment parce que c'est c'est
vraiment le plus important c'est de
passer un grand moment pour ces pandas
et pour tous les animaux aussi bien sûr
de ce zoo
[Applaudissements]
c'est là qu'elle soit
déjà sur menthon un mercato
alors la prononciation chinois s'appelle
yoann tout
pour être prêt
bon
sur le côté
[Musique]
en
fait on va vous dire qui et qui chat
les moines du doo hwan nouveaux amis et
je le fais bien
faire
alors
[Musique]
on a donc une vraie symétrie entre d'un
côté roanne doudou et de l'autre enfin
une doudou et erwan lily donc qui vient
encore une fois du nom des parents des
pandas et puis le lit vient du deuxième
caractère du nom en chinois de paris
paris donc lhi là d'où vient donc de
chengdu donc la capitale de la province
du sichuan c'est la province d'où
viennent ces pandas on voit là c'est un
symbole important entre non pas là paris
et pékin entre guillemets mais entre
paris et chengdu c'est à dire la
province d'origine de ces pandas vous
venez donc d'assister comme nous en
direct voilà à l'attribution officielle
des noms
chinois de ses jumelles bandas à condom
on avait vu la naissance en août dernier
une cérémonie en présence de deux stars
du sport de stars internationales
qui viennent m pap est évidemment que
tout le monde connaît et puis la
championne olympique de plongeon
synchronisé zhang yan shi l'un et
l'autre ont dévoilé les noms de ses
jumelles pour celle qui s'appelait
provisoirement fleurs de coton elle
s'appelle désormais juan leal y est
celle qui s'appelait petites neiges
s'appelle désormais juan doudou comme le
disait antoine banda's c'est évidemment
l'un des prénoms qui ont été des noms
qui ont été inspirés par leurs pères et
mères respectives à ces pandas et
inspire également par la capitale
française paris pour erwan lydie et par
la province dans laquelle sont
originaires les pandas historiquement
comme l'a rappelé une des responsables
du zoo et bien 40 cents mille cent
vingt-deux mille votants ont participé
au choix de ces prénoms ils ont été
sollicitées ces internautes par le biais
d'internet et 43% avait choisi le prénom
juan lilly pour ce qui est de deux
fleurs de coton nous sommes en direct
sur figaro lie pour vous faire vivre cet
événement on a donc vu l'essentiel de
l'attribution de ces dons et puis
évidemment ces images adorable des
pandas christian léon toussaint qui est
un internaute fidèles de figaro live lui
aussi est sous le charme il lit où ils
sont trop mignons et je pense que c'est
le commentaire et qui a dû être
prononcées ou pensé par nombre d'entre
vous qui vous suivez en direct antoine
bond has
tout à l'heure on donc on a longuement
évoqué cette ces enjeux diplomatiques
politiques dans dans la présence des
pandas dans des pays étrangers puisque
ce sont des prêts faits par la chine qui
est la seule à posséder des pandas ils
sont originaires de chine ces animaux
donc une stratégie on va dire politique
diplomatique derrière tout ça on parlait
donc de l'entretien de l'amitié entre
des pays et par le biais évidemment de
ces prêts d'animaux de la même façon
qu'ils sont prêtés 1 sursis ds qui
peuvent être rapatriés entre guillemets
en cas de conflit ou de refroidissement
des relations entre deux pays entre la
chine et la france par exemple alors
effectivement il peut l'être puisqu'ils
sont prêtés peuvent être entre
guillemets des prêté cette année
récupérer il y avait au milieu dès 2010
lors de la détérioration du début de la
détérioration des relations entre la
chine et les états unis à l'époque des
discussions sur le fait que peut être
indépendant de washington ou de
l'attentât seraient rapatriés entre
guillemets en chine c'est donc entre
guillemets un moyen potentiel de
pressions de la part de la chine mais
encore une fois je pense qu'il faut le
relativiser lorsque vous rapatriez un
panda évidemment ça a un impact
extrêmement négatif
et donc si le message que vous voulez
envoyer c'est celui d'une détérioration
assumé de la relation ok si le message
qui est envoyé celui que la relation
reste importante et que vous ayez trouvé
des moyens objectifs pour l'améliorer la
stabiliser alors évidemment rapatrier un
panda ne sera pas la bonne solution vous
le voyez sur ces images ces deux petites
bêtes
d'accord donc là
si vous ne retrouvez en direct désolé
pour cette interruption du flux suite à
des problématiques techniques voilà il
met renta voilà à l'informatique on va
dire nous étions donc en train de
commenter c'est cette cérémonie
cérémonie du nom en direct depuis le zoo
de beauval où les deux jumelles panda
néant le 2 août dernier se sont vus
attribuer des noms officielle en
présence de deux champions
internationaux en l'occurrence
quillanais mbappé que vous reconnaissez
malgré le masque champion du monde de
foot et puis la championne olympique de
natation synchronisée
zhang d'atik est la marraine chinoise de
cet événement est la marraine également
d'un des deux pandas comme l'est
d'ailleurs qui n aiment pas payer donc
parent d'un des deux d'un des deux
ursidés en l'occurrence ce sont des
femelles qui en mba paix et parrain de
yann godbout qui est donc un nom juan
doudou pardon antoine blondin à mes
côtés spécialiste de la chine va nous en
dire plus sur l'attribution de ces noms
avant qu'on se dise au revoir one doudou
pour le panda donc il n aime pas paix
est le parrain erwan leamy pour la
deuxième femme elle dont et marraines la
championne de plongeon synchronisé
chinoise effectivement et les noms sont
composées à partir du nom des parents de
ses deux jumelles donc juan et yuan yuan
doudou un le doudou vient de la ville de
chengdu qui est la capitale de la
province du sichuan dont sont
originaires ses pandas et le roi lily
évidemment vient de paris puisque en
chinois ont dit pâli et donc le lit est
doublé et donc voilà c'est un symbole à
la fois pour rendre hommage aux parents
de ces deux jumelles et puis aussi aux
relations franco-chinoises entre
notamment paris et
chengdu donc la capitale du sichuan on
rappellera juste une anecdote en chinois
le panda se dit schumacher qui est
littéralement l'ours et le chat est donc
c'est la conjugaison de ces deux
caractères avec 7 de signification qui
signifie panda et donc voilà c'est un
grand jour entre guillemets pour les
français aussi pour les chinois puisque
tous les chinois ils ont bien raison
sont extrêmement fiers de cet animal
endémique de la chine qui n'est pas
simplement le symbole du wwf grande
organisation de trêve de préservation de
la nature qui avait décidé dans les
années 80 de faire du panda dans son
animal totem sur l'animal symbole c'est
aussi évidemment une grande fierté pour
tous les chinois en chine et à
l'étranger on va le dire vous parlez
d'un animal qui était en danger il ya
quelques dizaines d'années il est
toujours inscrit sur la liste rouge
mondiale des espèces menacées en 2016 il
est cependant passé de la catégorie
menacé à la catégorie vulnérable c'est
un animal très protégée aujourd'hui
il l'est toujours par la chine alors
qu'on voit sur ces images d'archivés la
naissance de ces pandas qui ressemble
pas du tout à ce qu'on pourrait imaginer
d'un panda à la naissance puisqu'ils
sont vraiment très petit
mais ils changent vite la preuve c'est
que à trois mois et demi presque on
vient de le voir sur les images en
direct et bien c'est déjà de belles
peluche comme disent certains
internautes qui sont évidemment extasié
devant les images toujours
attendrissante de ces pandas qui
réjouissent bon nombre d'entre vous
aujourd'hui comme nous mêmes merci
encore de nous avoir suivis en direct
sur figaro live merci pour vos
commentaires et votre fidélité à la fois
sur lefigaro.fr et sur notre chaîne
youtube merci beaucoup antoine blonde
has pour vos éclairages sur les
coulisses politiques et diplomatiques
liées à cette cérémonie je rappelle que
vous êtes chargé de recherche à la
fondation pour la recherche stratégique
vous êtes spécialiste des deux corées et
de la chine et que on vous retrouve
évidemment tout à fait présent sur les
réseaux sociaux et twitter en
particulier
merci encore beaucoup à très vite sur
figaro live